le dispositif navales en méditerranée et
allégé mais françois mitterrand averti
il n'appartient à personne me dicter à
la france ce qu'elle doit faire
des assises de la gendarmerie devant le
ministre jean pierre chevènement of un
nouveau directeur et promet uniforme
bâle kaserne effectifs aient droit à la
parole 600 millions de francs pour les
agriculteurs victimes de la sécheresse
un début pour le gouvernement une simple
goutte d'eau pour les syndicats
agricoles
henri tazoult qui rentre pour promettre
à l'automne plus choquant 88 et appelle
par surprise à l'unité syndicale
madame monsieur bonsoir à la une une
catastrophe qui n'en finit plus de
produire ses effets le 26 avril 1986 un
réacteur nucléaire explose attire nobill
il y à 32 morts officiels mais cinq à
dix mille cancer prévisible le mois
dernier l'union soviétique annoncé qu'un
million de personnes originaires de
cette région allait à nouveau être
déplacées à cause des risques continuent
de contamination aujourd'hui à
l'occasion d'un séminaire sur
l'environnement en italie le professeur
bunch of membre de l'académie des
sciences de l'union soviétique annonce à
une centaine de savants du monde entier
la catastrophe de tchernobyl a aussi
produit des mutants et des monstres
patrick esther dans le but d'étudier
d'éventuelles mutations des plantes les
soviétiques avaient construit des
grandes serres à proximité du lieu de
l'accident dans les mois qui avaient
suivi la catastrophe des cornichons
géant avait mûri mais les autorités ont
toujours démenti la rumeur publique
faisant allusion à des anomalies graves
de la nature animaux sauvages il ya de
longues oreilles ou fleurs ayant changé
de couleur or hier le professeur leonid
ball chauffe donc de la très officielle
academy version soviétique a confirmé
que dans la région de tchernobyl
les feuilles des chaînes ont changé de
couleur et doubler de taille
de même les branches des sapins au lieu
de pousser un retournement vers le sol
se sont mises à croître verticalement
mais il ya pire des mutations génétiques
chez les animaux les chattes ont donné
naissance à des petits qui n'entendent
pas les rattes ont mis au monde verra
très gros d'une dimension tout à fait
inhabituelle et ses animaux géants sont
aveugles
le rat qui se reproduit
rapidement peu en trois ans fournir des
indications sur ce qui risque d'arriver
chez l'homme dans plusieurs générations
ainsi les effets à long terme de la
catastrophe de tchernobyl pourrait
s'avérer pire que les effets immédiats
des radiations
merci patrick esther le liban on verra
peut-être bientôt jean paul ii à
beyrouth en tout cas le porte-parole du
vatican annonce qu'un déplacement du
souverain pontife dans la capitale
libanaise est envisagée on a appris
également dans l'après midi que le
dispositif naval français en
méditerranée au large de beyrouth allait
être allégée quelques heures plus tôt
françois mitterrand l'avait justifiée à
nouveau pour répondre aux accusations de
la syrie et de ses alliés et pour éviter
la récupération par le camp chrétien
bruno le greffe l'escadre français se
tient actuellement à plus de 200 milles
des côtes libanaises dans les eaux
internationales en attente
il y à la cie bâtiment protégé par un
système de défense anti-aérien
ultramoderne opérationnel pour la
première fois deux navires doivent
quitter la zone
leduc n est probablement le d'estienne
d'orves
le dispositif français donc allégé et se
tient pour l'instant à l'écart du liban
l'heure est à la diplomatie après avoir
obtenu le soutien de la cee et la
bienveillante neutralité des états unis
le gouvernement français doit maintenant
expliquer le déploiement de ses forces
navales
ce matin dans une interview à france
soir le général aoun déclare que la
france lui à livrer des munitions
faux répond le quai d'orsay qui précise
cependant qu'il n'ya pas d'embargo sur
les livraisons d'armements à destination
du liban quelques heures plus tard
cheikh fadlallah guide spirituel des
intégristes pro iranien assure que
l'intervention française pourrait
provoquer la destruction du liban
françois mitterrand répond en personne
au cours du conseil des ministres
d'aujourd'hui
tout d'abord aux syriens et à leurs
alliés il n'appartient à aucun groupe de
dicter à la france ce qu'elle doit faire
à propos du liban dit il puis au général
aoun
certains s'imaginent bien à tort que la
marine française est ou sera à leur
disposition
la france agit et agira conformément au
droit international assure le président
de la république ce soir à beyrouth les
hôpitaux lance un appel au secours
ils mentent pour la plupart de
médicaments de matériel d'urgence d'eau
et de fioul au cours des deux dernières
semaines
dix centres hospitaliers ont été
touchées par les bombardements
c'est dans ce contexte que cet
après-midi un pirate de l'air a réclamé
une conférence internationale sur le
liban ce n'était qu'un prétexte
le pirate un algérien expulsé de france
a tenté de détourner vers tunis
l'airbus d'air france qui assure la
liaison paris alger l'appareil s'est
finalement posé en algérie et le pirate
a été maîtrisé plus de peur que de mal
pour les 102 passage et saïd jamel était
seul et sans arme
il n'avait en fait que deux bouteilles
de parfum à la main il faisait l'objet
d'un arrêté d'expulsion pour entrave à
l'ordre public
il s'était montré particulièrement
agitée quand il avait été embarqué dans
ce vol par la force publique
les gendarmes ont une nouvelle tête en
conseil des ministres charles barbeau a
été nommé à la direction générale de la
gendarmerie poste qu'il occupait déjà
entre 79 et 84
il remplace monsieur régis mourier qui
fait sans doute les frais de plusieurs
semaines de grogne
c'était là le prélude à la table ronde
de cet après midi aux invalides face à
face et bâtons rompus pour jean pierre
chevènement et 87 gendarmes tirés au
sort
emmanuel vanier et michel jeannot latos
képi bas pour cette première dans la
gendarmerie
trois heures des négociations entre la
base et le ministre ils sont 87 dans
cette grande salle de l'hôtel des
invalides 87 officiers gradés et
sous-officiers tirés au sort parmi
quatre mille neuf cents volontaires aux
côtés de jean pierre chevènement le tout
nouveau directeur de la gendarmerie
ici au centre charles barbou nommé ce
matin en conseil des ministres une
nomination intervenue à l'aube d'une
journée qualifiée par le ministre
lui-même journée de l'ordre et du
progrès trois types de mesures adoptées
aujourd'hui elle concerne le recrutement
l'argent et les moyens d'expression
4000 emplois vont être créés en quatre
ans 3000 pour des gendarmes d'activ
emile auxiliaire c'est trois fois plus
que pendant la période 82 89 100
millions de francs de crédits pour le
fonctionnement quotidien des
gendarmeries vont être débloqués chaque
brigade disposera d'un crédit libre de
10 mille francs par an l'uniforme sera
désormais prise en charge par l'état
enfin 200 millions de francs seront
consacrés à la réfection des casernes
pas de syndicat pas d'association pour
les gendarmes a réaffirmé le ministre
mais cinq missions de réflexion vont
être constitués afin at il dit de
renouer le dialogue
si apparaît que des problèmes posés
depuis longtemps j insiste ont fini par
créer au fil des ans de véritables
anomalies
il faut savoir s'y attaquer dans l'ordre
et dans le respect des valeurs de
discipline et de subordination aux
droits qui font la force de la vannerie
si des appels à l'illégalité sont lancés
une boîte est sanctionné un dialogue
franc direct sans réticence a encore dit
jean pierre chevènement et des
propositions qui selon lui devrait
suffire à mettre un terme à la grogne
des gendarmes
alors justement quel et l'humeur des
gendarmes après cet exposé des motifs de
grogne et les réponses du ministre c'est
isabelle bessler qui a recueilli les
premières réactions
il faudrait tripler effectif vous savez
bien que pour un pote de gendarmes il
faut quatre policiers 1 il faut le dire
aussi
donc il faudrait tripler les effectifs
en un bris pour faire 40 heures ou 39
heures donc ce n'est pas possible n'a
rien eu au niveau de rotation mais je
dis hein je dis qu'on ne venait pas
chercher une augmentation
on va les chercher
de l'oxygène on va les chercher une
astreinte moins lourde
bonojean l'ordre espérons nous savons
être entendu
avait peu d'espoir mois
l'espoir fait vivre
moyen on sort de la réunion avec aucune
solution
ce sont des solutions à long terme de
lever l'impact a augmenté
quand vous voyez votre impôt enfants en
coup de vent chant en temps oui enfin
faudrait que parce vous savez c'est un
chandail n'est pas bien dans sa vie
privée dans sa tête c'est pas bien son
travail par les biens mais cette lettre
notre commission va se marier et son
usine une chose nouvelle donc et
création de commissions consultatives
qui vont je pense commencer à rassembler
et à se réunir à partir du mois de
septembre
donc ils vont discuter des problèmes de
faux puisqu'il est sympa pendant une
réunion qui durera 3 3 on va discuter
des problèmes de fond on dise on dégage
de grands axes
ces volontaires sont à saison et
nous sommes volontaires
optimisme mesuré donc l'est républicain
le journal as nancy a reçu ce matin une
lettre anonyme signée par un officier de
l'armée
celui ci précise qu'il n'appartient pas
à la gendarmerie affirme qu'il s'exprime
au nom de plusieurs collègues et conclut
l'armée dans son ensemble n'est pas
satisfaite
la grogne des gendarmes pourraient bien
être l'étincelle qui mettra le feu aux
poudres 600 millions de francs c'est la
somme que va débloquer le gouvernement
pour venir en aide aux agriculteurs
victimes de la sécheresse ce n'est qu'un
début pour henri nallet le ministre
l'agriculture
cette enveloppe en tout cas est mal
reçue par les syndicats agricoles
pour le snj a c'est une véritable
provocation pour la fnsea
c'est dérisoire elisabeth est vrai
première mesure des prêts à taux nul
d'un montant de 300 millions de francs
pour prendre en charge les intérêts des
prêts calamité contractées par les
agriculteurs
deuxième point des prêts à taux réduits
4 % sur deux ans maximum d'un montant de
200 millions de francs pour aider cette
fois les éleveurs en difficulté
troisième point des aides directes d'une
valeur de 80 millions de francs pour les
exploitations en déséquilibre financier
enfin des céréales européennes
d'intervention à prix réduits vont être
proposés aux éleveurs un dispositif sans
commune mesure avec le fameux plan
sécheresse de 1976 qui est loin de
rassurer les agriculteurs
si l'on répond aux agriculteurs qui sont
déjà énormément endetté et qui sont dans
des difficultés financières terrible
parce qu'ils ont dû acheter des aliments
pour nourrir leurs animaux par une
possibilité d'endettement supplémentaire
il arrive un moment où le seuil du
tolérable est dépassé et ceci nous le
constatons cette sécheresse 89 car cela
fait pour bon nombre d'agriculteurs dans
beaucoup de régions de france du grand
sud
cela fait la quatrième sécheresse en
disant qu'ils sont à assumer ce qui est
le plus important une fois encore
c'est que les familles d'agriculteurs
qui sont à l'heure actuelle dans la
peine qu'ils n'ont plus rien qui n'ont
plus de ressources puissent être dépanné
le plus rapidement possible et dans des
conditions qui soient très simple et au
cas par cas parce qu'il est aussi
extrêmement important que ce soit les
agriculteurs qui en ont vraiment besoin
et eux seuls qui bénéficient de ces
années demain mission difficile pour
henri nallet qui se rend dans la région
du lauragais il devra convaincre les
agriculteurs de l'efficacité de son plan
effectivement vide de demain donc d'en
inhaler dans le sud de les régions les
plus touchées la haute garonne l'aude et
le tarn
dans la plupart des départements du
sud-ouest les préfet restreignent le
droit des agriculteurs à puiser dans les
nappes souterraines et les rivières pour
arroser les cultures 4 millions et demi
de fonctionnaires verront leur salaire
augmenter de 1,2 pour cent 1er septembre
c'est une décision du conseil des
ministres
cette revalorisation prévue lé jugée
insuffisante par la cfdt et la cftc la
cgt elle fait sa rentrée
henri krasucki promettent un automne
plus chaud que l'an passé et surprise
appel à l'unité syndicale
gérard leclerc de l'ancien et du nouveau
pour la rentrée d'henri krasucki déjà
ancien la dénonciation de la politique
du gouvernement rocard selon la cgt
toujours plus d'austérité pour les
salariés et de profits pour les
privilégiés bref si le sol est longue et
vendez on est privilégié et favorise
l'éducation
il prévient davantage langois arabe et
la cgt d'inviter une nouvelle fois les
salariés à développer revendications et
actions dans les entreprises
mais henri krasucki va plus loin et
redécouvre les bienfaits de l'unité
syndicale
et nous disons à toutes les
confédérations que nous sommes prêts à
rechercher les terrains d'entente
possible sur les sujets brûlants
cette main tendue va rencontrer le
scepticisme des autres syndicats certes
tous se condamne la rigueur salariale et
les insuffisances de la politique
sociale du gouvernement
mais les organisations diffèrent sur les
priorités et les solutions l'encadrement
cgc prône une grande rencontre nationale
sorte de nouveau grenelle
force ouvrière et la cfdt préfère le
développement de la politique
contractuelle et des négociations à tous
les niveaux quant à la cgt elle préfère
l'action et les autres syndicats lui
reproche son dogmatisme et ses méthodes
le gouvernement lui observe et
privilégie toujours le règlement au cas
par cas un parent des conflits en
espérant éviter l'embrasement général
que certains annoncent l'offre publique
d'achat dessus assure le groupe
d'assurances victoire la banque paribas
indique cet après midi qu'elle ne
participera pas à la contre-offensive de
monsieur verne pdg de victoire pour
contrer loupé à de suez le gouvernement
a du mal avec son décret sur la
limitation des loyers parisiens la
commission nationale de concertation
elle réunit les pouvoirs publics les
locataires et les propriétaires elle
donne un avis défavorable nouveau projet
de décret établit par le ministère des
finances en pologne toujours du neuf les
dernières tractations avant que monsieur
mazowiecki une forme son gouvernement et
va les acquis disait ce matin les
communistes auront des postes s'il nous
le demande gentiment et puis cet après
midi le parlement polonais a condamné à
l'unanimité le pacte ribbentrop molotov
il est qualifié d'infâmes le pacte
germano soviétique signé en 1939
prévoyait dans une clause secrète le
partage de la pologne entre l'allemagne
nazie et l'union soviétique de staline
ont manifesté cet après midi à varsovie
devant l'ambassade soviétique antenne 2
à varsovie
jacques merlino et dominique merlet
celuici dodo moulay soviétique à la
maison à bas le communisme et slogan
était sans ambiguïté cet après midi
devant l'ambassade soviétique à varsovie
saisissant l'occasion du 50e
anniversaire du pacte ribbentrop molotov
qui organisa en 1939 le partage de la
pologne entre l'allemagne nazie et
l'urss stalinienne 2000 manifestants ne
cachaient pas leur sentiment
une telle manifestation jusque devant
les grilles de l'ambassade soviétique
est un événement exceptionnel dans ce
pays
il est révélateur de la liberté d'esprit
qui accompagne le changement politique
celui-ci se prépare soigneusement sous
la conduite de tadeusz mazowiecki
le plus difficile pour lui est de
constituer un gouvernement en ne
laissant aux communistes que les
ministères de l'intérieur et de la
défense
ce matin devant les élus de solidarité
il a expliqué qu'il devait faire face à
une situation délicate puisque le parti
communiste qui saura son opposition
détiendra également le contrôle de la
police et de l'armée
les obligations du pacte de varsovie kr
est ici une situation sans précédent va
les acquis qualifie encore michael
gorbatchev de grands jongleurs il dit
qu'il admire et souhaitent le rencontrer
le pacte germano-soviétique provoque
aussi une grande agitation dans les
provinces balle l estonie la lettonie et
la lituanie annexées par moscou
sept cent mille personnes font une
chaîne humaine pour commémorer le 50e
anniversaire de ce pacte philippe
boisserie
une chaîne humaine de 560 km pour
commémorer le fera plus tard manu body
le temps est venu de
23 août 1939 ribbentrop molotov signant
un pacte dont un protocole secret
stipule que les pays baltes
appartiennent à la sphère d'influencé de
moscou
moins d'un an après tallinn annexer les
trois états
aujourd'hui estoniens lituaniens et
lettonien ne reconnaissent aucune
légalité à ce protocole à coups de
pétitions de déclarations de commissions
parlementaires il réclame l'indépendance
pure et simple
mais face aux six millions de balles et
plus de deux millions et demi d'immigrés
russes craignent de plus en plus de voir
leurs droits remise en cause le
parlement estonien a récemment restreint
leur droit de vote une loi déclarée
anticonstitutionnelle par moscou mikhaïl
gorbatchev tente tant bien que mal
d'enrayer le mouvement
il faut poser aux baltes l'indépendance
économie devant la foule des
manifestants la mesure semble
aujourd'hui insuffisant
les policiers allemands de bavière ont
découvert dans un camion garé dans un
quartier de munich 650 kg de cocaïne
il y en a pour 710 millions de francs
c'est une saisie record
la drogue aurait été acheminé par bâteau
de colombie jusqu'au port allemand de
bremerhaven pour la police locale les
cartes de la drogue d'amérique latine
les cartels de la drogue d'amérique
latine ont transféré leur stratégie vers
l'europe en raison de l'accroissement de
la lutte anti drogue aux états unis en
colombie
la gigantesque opération anti drogue se
poursuit la police et l'armée sont
mobilisés et la ville de medellin c'est
la capitale des trafiquants évacuer
d'ailleurs par les caïds et cerner rémy
roche visite des villes les domaines des
caïds du cartel de medellin
les propriétaires sont absents ils ont
été opportunément prévenus peu avant le
déclenchement de la gigantesque
opération anti-drogue de ces derniers
jours un luxe extravagant jusqu'au
moindre détail
l'un d'entre eux a même installé un zoo
sur ses terres un autre a surmonté le
portail d'entrée de sa propriété de
l'avion à bord duquel il effectue à sa
première livraison de cocaïne aux états
unis en colombie les gros bonnets de la
drogue ont un certain humour ce sont
également des bienfaiteurs c'est en tout
cas ce qu'on a envie
à medellin leur fief à 500 km au
nord-ouest de bogota
il offre maison aux pauvres terrain de
football quand ils ne distribuent pas
tout simplement des billets de banque
dans les rues aux nécessiteux l' empire
est également un gros employeur
puisqu'il contrôle 25 mille hectares
reconverti depuis dix ans dans la
culture de la feuille de coca bien
récolte peut-on faire l'année cinq
récompenses c'est beaucoup si on compare
au manioc
oui oui c'est beaucoup vous rendez
compte cinq récoltes et il peut être
content prévoyez le paye cash
toute la coca n'est pas cultivée en
colombie la bolivie et le pérou sont
également de gros producteurs mais la
cocaïne transformer transit elle presque
toujours par medellin bénéfice annuel
entre 4 et 6 milliards de dollars à
l'échelle d'une telle puissance les
moyens de lutte mis en place par les
autorités colombiennes semble dérisoire
tout juste quelques actions
spectaculaires la corruption massive
empêche d'aller plus loin
quand ça n'est pas la terreur juge
journalistes et leaders politiques sont
déjà tombés par dizaines sous les balles
des tueurs payé par le cartel 80% de la
cocaïne consommée aux états unis arrive
de colombie on comprend dès lors
l'impatience de washington où certains
proposent une assistance militaire sur
place
il peut être conseillé encore par le
ministre colombien des affaires
étrangères
alors les américains réclament
l'extradition des leaders ils en ont
obtenu pour l'instant qu'une seule celle
de carlos traders qui purge depuis 1987
une peine de réclusion à vie dans une
prison d'illinois mai bogota a fait
savoir qu'en vertu d'un décret spécial
romero considéré comme le financier du
cartel de medellin est arrêtée lundi
pourrait lui aussi être jugé par la
justice américaine
notre information en france avec agnès
poirier
finn il y un an presque jour pour jour
delphine disparaissait en pleine nuit de
son camp scout dans le calvados
des gens plus tard on découvrait son
corps calciné à 20 km de là après les
centaines d'interrogatoires l'anc est
aujourd'hui au point mort le plus petit
témoignage le moindre indice soulignent
les gendarmes de caen peut constituer un
début de piste
dimanche dernier il avait fait sauter
les verrous de la porte de la prison de
rennes avec du plastique
les deux détenus en cavale ont été
repérés en banlieue parisienne
hier soir ils ont gagné paris dans la
voiture d'un gars de pêche selon cet
homme qui a pu leur fausser compagnie
les fuyards n'ont pas préparé leur
cavale et serait aux abois
sept corps repêché hier dans la tamise
dernier bilan du naufrage du martinez 31
morts et 26 disparus déterminer le
nombre exact des personnes sur le bateau
a été difficile affirmé policier de
scotland yard
en l'absence d'une liste des passagers
il y à 79 survivants
le four à micro ondes à nouveau contesté
en décembre dernier la revue américaine
science estimé que ce procédé ne
détruisez pas certains parasites du
poisson aujourd'hui le ministère anglais
de l'agriculture considère que la
cuisson micro-ondes ne détruit pas
certaines bactéries et que ce four
pourrait être à l'origine
d'empoisonnement alimentaire par exemple
les salmonelloses marie-françoise
grillon le four à micro-ondes
laisserait-il par excès de zèle apprécié
pour sa rapidité il n'en fait pas le
temps de stériliser complètement les
aliments micro-ondes est un appareil qui
est utilisée pour remonter en
température ou pour réchauffer des
aliments et non pas pour les assainir
comme l'ont fait dans une opération de
cuisson ou de pasteurisation les
températures nécessaires pour assurer
l'assainissement sont de l'ordre de 65 à
85 degrés est au dessus et à maintenir
pendant plusieurs minutes dans un four à
micro ondes
on n'atteint pas le plus souvent ces
températures
par conséquent on ne peut pas en avoir
pour notre objectif de détruire les
microbes en question
une chose est certaine micro-ondes agi
trop vite pour pouvoir c'est réaliser
efficacement
il est donc nécessaire de ne lui confie
que des aliments irréprochable préparer
et conserver ce nom des règles d'hygiène
strictes pour avoir les mains très très
bon on doit avoir également une tenue
vestimentaire impeccable ces aliments
doivent être sortis des frigidaires
l'année instant doit pas traîner à la
chaleur pour moi professionnels le
micro-ondes n'est pas un instrument de
cuisson c'est un instrument de remise en
température le réchauffage et en aucun
cas d'une cuisson au wok ce soit dans un
micro il faudrait aussi que les
industriels et les commerçants fassent
preuve de la plus grande rigueur pour en
particulier ne pas rompre la chaîne du
froid
c'est à cette condition aussi que les
aliments arriveront sans microbes dans
nos assiettes c'est loin très très très
loin aux limites du système solaire que
se promène actuellement la sonde
voyageurs de lancer le 20 août 1977 il y
à 12 ans elle a successivement sur relay
jupiter puis saturn puis elle a été
tellement performantes que les
scientifiques qui ont envoyé du côté de
neptune neptune
c'est avec pluton les deux planètes les
plus lointaines du système solaire par
rapport à la terre voyageurs 2 nous
offre ces images de neptune patrick
esther un voyage de six mille milliards
de kilomètres qui aura duré douze ans la
sonde américaine a accéléré
progressivement sa vitesse pour
atteindre 68 mille kilomètres heure dans
deux jours encore accélérée par neptune
elle poursuivra sa course à plus de cent
mille kilomètres heure l'engin le plus
rapide jamais construit par l'homme
auparavant elle nous aura envoyé huit
mille images une moisson de découvertes
par exemple on ne connaissait jusqu'ici
que deux satellites à neptune la sonde
en a déjà identifié quatre nouveaux de
même les images montre distinctement des
anneaux autour de la planète
mais surtout la caméra de voyageurs 2 à
photographier un gigantesque cyclone
s'étendant sur treize mille kilomètres
de long
ce qui prouve du même coup que neptune
dispose d'une atmosphère composée de
nuages blancs formé de méthane toutefois
guère de chance de trouver là-bas des
formes de vie puisque la température à
la surface n'est que de moins de 100
degrés après avoir survolé en
rase-mottes triton la plus importante
l'une de neptune
l'engin sortira définitivement du
système solaire il essentiel est donc à
venir c'est dans 24 heures que la sonde
américaine frôlera entre trois et six
mille kilomètres neptune avant de se
perdre au delà du système solaire
patrick et sterling holding olivier
debré à 50 ans ce peintre est l'un des
papes de l'abstraction lyrique gestuelle
autrement dit est schématiquement il
pointe en dansant devant la toile et il
signe d'ailleurs aujourd'hui 160 m² de
tableau qui serviront de rideau à
l'opéra de hong kong
le tout a été emballé dans une dans une
pièce dans une caisse de 17 mètres de
longueur qui sera acheminé lundi par
avion spécial en asie du sud est
gérard dalmas issy les moulineaux et son
rideau il est né sous une bulle
le petit dernier d'olivier debré 10
mètres sur 16 le rideau de scène peint à
la main le plus vaste du monde
novembre 89 en présence du prince
charles
ce raid est signée d'un des plus grands
artistes contemporains s'ouvrira sur
fidelio premier spectacle du nouvel
opéra de hong kong pour ce nouveau
monstre du lyrique aride au monstre
commandé par la fondation vuitton 160 m²
100 kg de peinture à l'huile sur l'un
tendu d'où les sacs de plastique en
guise de pantoufles dominante un jaune
très symbolique de la chine éternelle
pas fait par ma voix
le jaune citron alès ans quand même
apparaître des endroits où il ya le
cadmium play soit quand même pas trop
acide et pour que ta joue et un
enchaînement avec les rouges et semaine
de balai brosse avec chaque jour de la
force et de la spontanéité c'est
l'abstraction lyrique gestuelle un
occident est arrivé aux gestes qui
propose des motions et donc ont rejoint
la calligraphie extrême orientale le
geste et dans celui qui bat il bat
gauche en haut à droite
quel que soit et il y assure chez lui de
l'espoir monthey en normalement
droitière celui monde il faut à chaque
fois être plein émission plein de porz
plein de bourse
le geste soit blanc et boucla oui la vie
traverse
ça ne peut pas être fait avec une
froideur n'ont senti pour à chaque fois
véritablement que l'on vit vraiment la
planète
olivier debré c'est le jaillissement
d'une éruption solaire le champ des
forces de la nature
ce rideau tableau c'est une colline
intégré au paysage
par exemple le sport avec les
championnats du monde sur route
l'allemagne de l'est enlève le titre
mondial du 100 km contre la montre par
équipes amateurs devant la pologne et
l'union soviétique les français sont
sixièmes en 50 50 km contre la montre
dames la france obtient la brûle
médaille de bronze la médaille de bronze
derrière l'italie et l'union soviétique
les françaises sans longo mais avec la
jeune espoir marsal il y un tiercé
demain à vincennes voici les pronostics
de pierrette brès le 16 le 17 le cap
torge le 11 le 13 le 15 le 9 et le 8
dans un instant le temps la météo avec
laurent cabrol dernier journal avec
henri sannier demain 13h retrouverez
william leymergie à demain 20h
excellente soirée à tous sur antenne 2